wednesday
p-f-t-o-t where we get an opportunity to
talk about things we weren't able to
squeeze into the two hours that we had
on nbcsn
and this caught my attention yesterday
chris because
i i kind of knew it was coming although
it surprises me because
ultimately there's no real basis for it
a report from nfl media the
conglomerate owned and operated by the
nfl that the nfl has floated the
possibility
of salary give backs by players
to offset the losses that are expected
this year
if and when the nfl has to play games in
empty or partially filled
stadiums there's been an estimate of
five and a half billion dollars
that the league would lose if games go
forward throughout the course of the
season without fans
that's ticket sales parking concessions
merchandise etc
even though the games are going to be
played the nfl
floating this idea of the players giving
back some of the money they are due to
make this year
i look at it on the surface chris and i
say hey the salary cap is set
the salaries are set there's no
provision
in the labor deal that allows the nfl to
come back and say
oh you know what uh we uh
we expect to make less money than we
thought we were going to make when we
set the salary cap
we want everyone to cut their pay by 10
there's no device for that
there's no cause for it there's nothing
the nfl can do to make it happen
and that's reason alone for the nflpa to
say sorry
the deal's the deal right we hear that
all the time when right
there's something about the cba that the
players don't like oh sorry players the
deal's a deal and the and the media
jumps
in a bad deal why the player is a bad
deal
yeah so nfl and this would be the
response
why didn't you put something in there
that if there is some unforeseen event
that causes
expected revenues to dramatically
decrease
for the year where the salary cap is set
and the salaries are already
set in stone there's some device to go
across the board
with a commensurate reduction in player
salary based on how much revenue is lost
just put it in there
if you want that protection don't don't
don't pull it out of thin air when you
find yourself
in a circumstance you didn't plan for
yeah right well you know you know we
talked about this a few weeks ago the
the lack of the
the the force mature right clause
it's it's not we don't see it in the nfl
cba and
uh i'm proud of myself that i got that
word right but
regardless yes it's not there uh i don't
know what the nfl was thinking about
in as far as that aspect of it um i
guess the other thing too
mike i want to say first off is you know
listen
at the end of the day if i want anybody
to take on the financial burden of what
can happen here with the nfl i want the
owners it's 32 billion
billionaires sorry i'm not gonna ask the
player who's come from nothing and now
the first time he's gonna make a little
change in money in his life to go hey
take a pay cut or
take less than you know is it is there
less than
the normal risk of playing the football
game without fans there there's more
there's more risks if playing right amid
a pandemic
the risk is greater for the players and
it doesn't matter like derwent james is
not going to be like well
i'll tackle you nicer because there's no
fans in the cro
he's gonna still try to knock your head
off when you come over the middle
jamal adams whatever you know whatever
linebackers are out there so
the risk is still very real the risk is
still to the point where
an nfl football player is going to be
able to get hurt and maybe ruin his
career and never be able to play again
so that's where it's different than the
other sports because of the physicality
the injury history
the low career rate it's different than
basketball and baseball
those injuries happen few and far
between
and then the other aspect mike of course
is yes i understand the nfl will lose
money
but not compared to the other sports
again we're in a sport that
tv viewership drives the dollars up
more than anything and i know fans are
important and of course all that money
that comes along with fans of the
stadium
it's a big deal but not nearly as big as
major league baseball or nba basketball
i mean come on
we see preseason games get as good of
ratings as nba finals games that just
tells you how powerful football is so
it's not like they're going to lose the
big piece of the pie
revenue as compared to what baseball and
basketball
will lose with no fans and then hey we
go into next year and we figure it out
then but i i think that's going to be a
hard ass to ask the players to do that
yeah and i agree with you completely and
and look the only devices in the cba
that protect the nfl there are two of
them
one is in the standard player contract
and there's an argument to be made if
there are no games played at all
in a given season then the player's
eligibility for salary never commences
because the way it's written
they're paid when the first game is
played if there's never a game they
don't get paid that would be the
argument that's it
if there's cancellation of games then
there's an obligation by the two sides
to get together
and negotiate what the salary cap will
be
the following year based upon the actual
lost revenues
this year i mean this year's salary cap
is driven by the money that was made
last year not what they expect to make
this year that affects
next year's cap so that's when the
argument should happen that's when the
discussion
would occur and the nflpa would have the
ability to fully and completely audit
all of the records to make sure that the
losses really are what they're saying
instead of something that just gets
concocted on the fly hey we're going to
have a rough year
we'd like you to give up 10 of your pay
no that's not how it works
in a collectively bargained labor
relationship the rules are spelled out
and here's what they'll do potentially
chris here's the way to save money
if you anticipate reduced revenues you
go
to veteran players a couple of weeks
before the start of the season
veterans who have non-guaranteed
contracts and you say to them
well you know what you do to make 6
million this year we want you to take
4 million instead and if you don't we're
going to cut you and oh by the way
by cutting you in the middle of august
you really aren't gonna have any other
options
you're not gonna see four million or six
million or maybe even two million
if we make you a free agent all of a
sudden that's their
that's their hand that's their device
but you know you're right but you know
what
they do it anyway they do it anyway
right
are they they're gonna they're gonna be
even more aggressive about cutting
veterans
when they've got a bunch of rookies and
undrafted players who weren't there for
an offseason program
and you're just gonna hope that those
guys don't screw up your season
yeah you're exactly right i think that's
ultimately like the coaches
will have anarchy on their hands but
they're going to go what i i don't care
i want to pay this veteran defensive
tackle six million dollars
i know we have a backup who's a rookie
who's making 700
000 but you know i don't think he'll be
able to handle double team
you know whatever it may be you're just
going to go our team might fall apart
this guy's not ready for the nfl yet
like you said he has no otas he doesn't
understand
you know all the nuances of the scheme
of the defense and things like that so
i you know that is a device that's
available for teams but
you know i think if teams dabbled in
that area too much
they're going to find that their teams
aren't going to win football games
either
and that's going to hurt them so uh
again i
you know if there's no games played or
there's less than
16 games played yes i would hope that
the nfl pa could come to an agreement
that okay we'll
we'll find a a rate that works for all
of us or you know we take those two
games or three games that we missed in
the regular season and
we prorate it to what your normal salary
is going to be
but i think ultimately what i come back
to more than anything
and it's just the fact that there's
still going to be tremendous risk for
players
and the risk of ruining your career or
ending your career with one hit or one
you know wrong step on astr you know
turf or whatever it may be to where
things are different and
that's going to be tough but mike this
is what i ask you
i don't mean do you think where do you
think the nfl players are on this like i
do you think they'd be willing to take
less to play if the owners come to the
table with this
well but here's the thing what do we get
in return for taking yes what are you
giving it
are you just asking us out of the
goodness of our heart to take less
because you're going to make less money
that goes back to what scott boris the
baseball agent said
a couple of weeks ago because baseball
working through these same issues
you don't privatize the gains and
socialize the losses
right in any other year when the money
comes through as expected
the owners keep theirs they
they sock it away as profit and the
value of their franchise continues to go
up
and up and up the players have no equity
the the player's only equity is their
body
and the number of years that their body
will allow them to play football at a
high level
so um i i don't i don't think the
players
should should even begin the
conversation until as you said
if games are missed then i think it
becomes reasonable to say
okay you've got you've got 16 games
and your salary is 16 million uh we're
we're only going to play 14 games so
will you take a salary of 14 million
will we just agree that your weekly rate
is applied to the number of games we
play and you know what under the cba
again because there's no forced major
clause
the players can say no they can say no i
know
f you pay me is what they can say we'll
deal with it next year
we'll figure it out next year when it's
time to potentially reduce the cap
because here's the other thing too
good luck getting all 32 owners on the
same page about reducing the salary cap
you think jerry jones wants to reduce
the salary cap
you think jerry jones is going to cut
key players because it's going to be
something that softens the financial
blow that he's going to feel this year
with no fans in the stands
hell no and that's why chris i made the
point yesterday
that by floating this theory through the
nfl's
in-house media conglomerate the union is
now
on notice for potential coordination
i.e collusion in the event
that all of a sudden every team starts
cutting
a certain number of veteran players and
shedding a certain percentage
of salary obligations this year they all
coincidentally
cut 10 percent oh well we're gonna do
that anyway okay
but you all cut 10 percent that that is
the kind of thing that they need to be
watching for
from and you and i know you have strong
feelings about this because it directly
affected your buddy kyle shanahan
the uncapped year of 2010 the cowboys
and washington had the misfortune of
treating it as uncapped
and they how dare they after the fact
how dare you treat the uncapped ears
uncapped
and they lost millions in salary cap
space
after the fact there is collusion from
time to time it's very easy to do it
it's very easy to get away with it and
the nfl whether they realize it or not
has i said i think put a flag in the
ground for the nflpa to be
watching for the possibility of
collusion this year as it relates to
veterans getting squeezed or cut in
order to
offset the losses that the teams now
expect if they're not going to have
full capacity uh in the stance
yeah no and i i think you know the the
point you bring up about jerry jones and
you know like we've talked about before
he's you know
up there in years he's trying to win a
super bowl before it's all said and done
he wants one more ring you're right i
don't think he's going to be the type of
owner that's going to want to sash
the slashes his salary cap payroll next
year
just because he's going to go well i'm
the dallas cowboys i got a lot of money
in the bank and we're going to make a
ton of money this year when fans are
back in the stands or whatever
he's going to look at it that way and uh
you're you're right i don't know if
you'll be able to get all 32 owners
on the same page but no the big thing is
is again we just look at
more little little hurdles not little
hurdles but hurdles that
i hope the nfl pa and the nfl can get
going on these conversations and iron
out some of these details
because i don't want there to be a fight
here leading into august and cutting
into training camp or cutting out games
because we haven't figured out the
contract situations
well here's hoping that the nfl doesn't
try to take positions that it's cba does
not allow it to take
you've bought that's very true for the
deal the deal is the deal
live with the deal and if you're going
to propose something like that you
better bring something to the table
you better have a concession ready for
the players
because look they've got no power to
compel them to do it the only way they
can do it is through arm's length
negotiation chris
and and and you can do side agreements
all the time you can you can't hey
if the union wants to cut player pay
cut everybody's base salary by 10 that's
fine
what are you giving us in exchange for
doing something
that we have no obligation to do and you
know what
the nfl is always quick to say
well this is the subject of labor
negotiation anytime marijuana policy
well that's the subject of labor
negotiation well this is two
so you better be ready to give them
something nfl if you want to take away
some of their money
because they have the rights to their
money as baked into the cba
that you've negotiated period yeah yeah
and you know
i all right so what do you think if
there's no games played like
do you do you think they're going to
play they're playing yeah they're
playing
all right they're playing and i have
nothing more to say about this i i agree
with you too i do
i i guess what i was gonna say too i was
just trying to say is
if there's no games played our players
still gonna be expected to pay
if the games start and then we gotta
have a halt for the season because
there's a coven 19
outbreak and everything like that what
happens in that scenario
you know that go ahead what were you
going to say that's when it becomes
interesting
if they're right because the way it was
explained to me
when this all first came up and i saw
that the nba
had a forced major clause in its cba i
went to the nfl cba i found the nba's
force major clause there it is plain and
simple went to the nfl cba
searched 20 different terms skimmed
through the whole document no forced
major clause
the the only thing that's in there as i
mentioned is in the standard player
contract
there's an argument to be made that if
they don't play any games at all the
obligation to pay base salary
never vests there's never a moment to
start paying them
so the nfl's position if push comes to
shove would be
if we play one game you get your full
salary if we play no games you get
nothing
now the nfl may try to finagle something
that would be
well if we only play partial game but no
what's in the cba and the in the union
agrees with me on this
what's in the cba is if there are games
missed
it it creates an obligation to negotiate
in good faith
on the next year's salary cap and just
the mere fact
that the cba contemplates the
possibility of games being canceled
and doesn't say in the event that games
are cancelled player salary will be
reduced in a commensurate amount that
would be the time to say it so that's
the argument
you could have put it in there you could
have asked for it you could have added
it
and and provided full clarity everyone
knows their rights
without it the players have a right if
the season begins
the players have a right to get their
full pay now the reality is
definitely affects the salary cap next
year if the owners have
no revenue and pay out full salary for
players
but under the cba as it's written you
deal with it next year chris
yeah yeah that's right you know and i uh
i don't have any more to say about the
subject but i think we hit it all i'm
i'm i've no more use for this my brain
is fried so
uh i think we hit all the points it was
a good talk your brain is fried for
other reasons
probably that too detox to retalks detox
it's coming your friday is tomorrow i
think tomorrow
especially in the summer time i'd love
to have a three-day weekend every week i
would
love to have you it does i think it
feels let me tell you let me tell you a
secret
we don't work anyway we would oh i got
to get up at 6 a.m to come talk about
football for two hours
in about 15 minutes after that oh boy
what a chore that is and i'm grateful
for that
trust me folks and and to actually chris
today
is the 20-year anniversary of the day
that i tripped into this business
it's the day that i pulled up a website
that i followed religiously at the time
they were they were looking for writers
and i said
oh what the hell i'll throw something
together and send it in
that was the moment that was the day
this morning 20 years ago today how
about wow
pretty special man it really is you
built something special
it's the go-to website for anybody
that wants to be in the know for
football and i mean i know that
coaches owners they don't like to admit
it because they don't always want to
give you credit because you're not
always
exactly you know what i appreciate about
you you know you're not political
you say it how it is or what you think
there's not a lot of filter there you're
not worried about being friends or
making friends with every person in the
nfl
and i respect that and i know i've been
uh a long
long time uh not necessarily a listener
but watcher of your
website and of course i love working
with you and this is special and it's
really cool
way to go man and thank you let me just
say one last thing
i've gotten some good feedback behind
the scenes from people in positions of
power and influence in the nfl who
actually appreciate
what we're saying and what we're doing
as it relates to the issues going on in
society right now they may not
appreciate the criticism that i'll
direct at the nfl
uh but they do appreciate the things
we're saying and and
some do some do not all but some
appreciate the fact that we're using
this platform to uh
to call for change and and as we've kind
of pivoted today toward calling for
action not just statements not just
words
what are people going to do so that's
something we'll continue to track
and uh hopefully we can we can use this
platform
for good uh the opportunity is here we
didn't pick it
we'd prefer not to be dealing with it
but now that it's here chris
you know together we roll up our sleeves
and we try to come up with a way to make
things better
yeah i mean that's all we can do i mean
we got to make it better we have to
if this is it's not acceptable what's
going on in our country right now
and yeah we're two guys that are we're
not going to shy away from these type of
conversations
you know as much as people want to try
to make it a a political conversation or
not it's not
this is not a political political
conversation it's crossed over into the
news of our sport that we cover
the players that play in the sport that
we cover are passionate about it
therefore it makes it very relevant to
the sport of football news right now
and that's why we're talking about it
let alone we care about people and
humans and society
and america and all of those things to
go along with it
something i i mentioned last week on the
pft pm podcast when i was answering
questions about what was going on and it
was
five days ago but it feels like it was
five years ago um
you either care about the rights and the
well-being of others or you don't
there really isn't middle ground there
either you care about other people
or you don't either believe believe
everyone should be treated with equity
and justice and fairness
or you don't right not oh i kind of
do you either do or you don't and and
this is a great
opportunity to smoke out the people who
don't and it's not all that hard to spot
them
no it's not it is not hard and you're
right there's a lot of people that want
it both ways
and then it's not right and it drives me
crazy
uh and they support you know some ideas
and things that go on in this country
sometimes where i just go
that's wrong that's backwards you know
you can't support that and then tell me
you're not
racist or you know you don't have an
issue there because that
thing you're supporting shows a lot of
issues in the racism category as
is so um i think uh you know hopefully
we're shedding some light shedding some
knowledge and
and uh we're in it for the good fight i
know that
well at this rate i'm going to need to
move to connecticut and get a medical
card like you have
uh i feel like closer and closer to it
being
to it being uh pharmaceutically
necessary for me to uh to augment the
periodic glass of wine or or a mug of
beer all right that's it for today folks
we appreciate
your loyalty we appreciate you listening
we appreciate you being willing
to act uh we all just want to make the
world a better place uh for our kids
for our grandkids and for for the future
uh
this crap has been lingering for far too
long and now is the moment to change it
all right chris thanks great stuff as
always and we'll see you in the match
again tomorrow
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports